lawyers for Donald Trump have started
talking with Robert Muller special
investigation staff about what a Trump
interview with his investigators might
look like and this is because Trump's
lawyers are probably correctly guessing
that eventually molars investigation is
going to get to Trump personally since
how could it not since Trump is clearly
being investigated personally and on the
table and we know why is the idea that
instead of an in-person interview with
molars team that Donald Trump would
participate by writing written responses
to Robert Muller rather than actually
having to go in there and sit down in a
live interview
I wonder why Donald Trump's attorneys
would prefer that he just submit written
answers to Robert Muller another part of
the discussion is whether Trump would be
interviewed if there was to be an
interview directly by robert muller or
by some of his staff and more than
likely it seems that it would be mauler
staff not Muller personally and there of
course also examining whether the
president can even be interviewed in
these investigations there there are
multiple sources that say that what
Trump's lawyers are really looking for
is some kind of legal justification to
say you can't actually interview the
president himself because it would cause
some kind of conflict or problem or
security issue this is not actually a
new conversation for Trump's lawyers
internally back when Paul Manafort was
indicted Trump's legal team his personal
legal team started strategizing and
talking about how can we keep Muller
away from Trump here but we're getting
closer and closer to the time when it's
just going to be time for Trump to go in
there and talk to them and that's when
it really starts to get funny a second
person familiar with what Trump's
lawyers are proposing or thinking about
says that Trump's lawyers have the idea
that maybe it would be acceptable for
Trump to skip the written question and
answers for Trump to skip the in-person
interview and just to write an affidavit
where he says I did nothing wrong and
didn't collude with Russia and that
would be it yeah because that would be a
really trustworthy piece of paper right
what do analysts think they basically
think that Donald Trump if he is thought
to be involved
you've got to bring him in personally
the affidavit is BS and that it would be
very unlikely that robert molars team
would agree to just written questions
and answers you got to get him in there
you got to get him in the chair and
you've got to talk to him I don't know
whether Trump's lawyers really think
that maybe I didn't do anything wrong on
a piece of paper with suffice or just
written question and answers it's not
clear but the concern if your Trump's
lawyer is that you have to realize
within five minutes of sitting down with
Moeller's team Trump's going to
incriminate himself even if he's not
guilty of anything
that's just how Trump is he finds ways
to create new problems for himself and
that's how we have the Russia
investigation that we even have today
though I was trying to think is there
any way that we might be able to
convince Trump that this is a good idea
if you went to trump and he said listen
we want to film your meeting with robert
muller and we're gonna make it a
pay-per-view event and you're gonna get
just gigantic ratings on TV and we'll
give you 80% of the pay-per-view revenue
maybe then Trump would say I'm gonna do
it because my interview with Robert
Muller is going to beat all prior
records for any interviews with Robert
millimolar in history and I'm gonna make
the big bucks and is gonna be absolutely
huge I don't know but I think everybody
who's working for Trump realizes that
this would be an absolute and total
disaster for Trump to go into that room